est ce que vous me croyez si je vous dis
que ça fait plus de sept mois qu'on n'a
pas parlé de star wars
j'ai envie de résoudre ça aujourd'hui
mais je vous avoue que la vidéo sera un
petit peu différente de d'habitude pas
de grosses théorie mais plusieurs
réflexions autour de l'univers que ce
soit marvel star wars ou même harry
potter nous sommes toujours face au même
schéma
un univers avec une trame principale qui
s'agrémente de films reliés les uns aux
autres se rajoute à ça des livres des
comics des romans etc
mais la particularité est là dedans
c'est qu'avec le temps et le succès la
saga devient véritablement énorme et
attire beaucoup de monde est là dedans
il ya tout un aspect marketing et
commercial puisqu'il faut étendre
l'univers
il faut l'enrichir mais il faut
également continuer ce qui marche déjà
ce qui a fait que l'univers s'est fait
connaître
bien évidemment dans l'univers star wars
la trilogie a été précurseur de tout ça
est un sacré phénomène l'iconique et
charismatique dark vador la liaison avec
luke skywalker le mystérieux yoda le
vieux ben les jedi et les sith
l'empereur et j'en passe et des
meilleurs donc forcément pour entretenir
la hype et l'intérêt pour star wars
il faut enrichir cette histoire déjà
créé la prélogie arrivera donc par la
suite
alimentant fortement l'univers qu'est
star wars mais divisera quand même en
partie les fans surtout ceux de la
première heure bref le succès sera tout
de même là mais vous le savez star wars
aura par la suite au fil des années une
grosse traversée du désert
malgré les oeuvres secondaire qui
sortiront à côté et c'est là où c'est
très intéressant car disney rachètera la
saga et voudra produire dessus sauf
qu'en termes de marketing et tout
l'aspect commercial
quelle est la meilleure chose à faire
pour relancer star wars dans le coeur
des gens mais aussi faire découvrir aux
plus jeunes va continuer la trame
principale
en amenant des nouveaux personnages on
se retrouve donc avec la poste au logis
on retrouvera donc en
or l'histoire des skywalker l'héritage
de la famille un retour de yoda est
évidemment palpatine
sans parler évidemment de kayes lorraine
qui est le fils de en solo qui dans le
symbole est la parfaite fusion entre
passé et nouveautés du qu'il est un
nouveau personnage mettrait relié à la
trilogie d'origine donc voilà encore une
fois on étire la trame principale on
agrémente l'histoire des skywalker ont
fait revenir des choses ikonik pour hype
et oui on peut appeler ça du fan service
mais ce n'est pas forcément quelque
chose de mauvais le fan service
bref donc voilà je suppose que le futur
de la saga sera dans la même lignée que
les trois trilogies en rapport avec les
skywalker
c'est là la pertinence avec la posologie
nous avons atteint un point de rupture
ou l'histoire des skywalker est
définitivement terminée l'udc n'est plus
de ce monde
palpatine est définitivement détruit cai
lorraine le dernier des skywalker
n'existe plus et même si dans un élan
d'espoir et d'ouverture reprend le nom
skywalker l'histoire est véritablement
terminée et c'est ça que je trouve fou
après plus de 40 ans d'existence la saga
star wars va prendre un autre tournant
ce que je veux dire c'est que depuis
toujours les oeuvres majeures ne sont là
que pour enrichir l'histoire des
skywalker
tout comme roux guan qui est une
histoire relié à la première trilogie
est donc encore une fois l'histoire des
skywalker
mais aujourd'hui ce n'est plus pareil et
c'est comme si la post au logis avait
pour rôle de juste relancer la saga avec
des éléments déjà connus pour pouvoir
maintenant produire de nouvelles choses
pour l'univers
moi où je suis hype et aujourd'hui c'est
que mandaloriennes semble être en
quelque sorte ce qu'était la trilogie
d'origine de star wars la série est
précurseur pour amener une nouvelle
histoire à l'univers et surtout c'est la
première véritable série star wars
crédible sur télévision j'ai bien
conscience qu'il existe déjà clone wars
et rebels qui sont très populaires mais
les objectifs n'étaient pas réellement
les mêmes le côté dessin animé des
montres fortement que le but est de
donner envie aux enfants là avec mandat
lauriane disney cherche à toucher et
tout le monde et rentrer véritablement
dans le game des séries qui est
clairement le support le plus populaire
du temps actuel mandat lauriane amène
une nouvelle manière de consommer star
wars
or des films de nouvelles intrigues non
basées sur les skywalker et en même
temps reprend d'anciens éléments qui
étaient très secondaire pour en faire
des éléments principaux et ça je trouve
que c'est vraiment une très bonne idée
je parle bien évidemment de tout
l'aspect mandalore le personnage de
beaux catane ou même ahsoka tano
même si tous assez canon ils ont
toujours été des éléments hors film des
éléments qui agrémentent l'univers mais
qui ne sont pas si important que ça donc
voilà et avec le succès de mandat
lauriane disney a la preuve que le
format télévision marche du tonnerre et
que ça plaît alors ils vont balancer je
vous le dis en fait c'est simple disney
annonce toujours plein de choses autour
de star wars
sauf qu'évidemment tout ne prend pas
forcément vie ils attendent les retours
et surtout les résultats
bref on peut mentionner donc la série
prévu sur obi wan qui devrait voir le
jour ou même celle sur kassian en dehors
ce sont des séries dont nous connaissons
déjà le dénouement le futur de leur
histoire mais dont nous ne connaissons
pas le chemin un chemin qui va pouvoir
amener des éléments et des intrigues
relié à d'autres oeuvres hors skywalker
c'est là la nouvelle stratégie de disney
ont créé un film ou une série on prend
un élément et on l'exploitent par le
biais d'une série dédiée ou un film
dédié
comme je vous disais mandaloriennes
reprend un peu le rôle de la première
trilogie en amenant beaucoup de choses
inédites mais aussi en amenant des
éléments plutôt secondaire dans la
saison 2 de la série nous avons un
visuel sur ce qui est devenu boba fett
après l'épisode 6 et comme par hasard
une série sur boba fett est prévu ou un
film on ne sait pas trop encore mais je
penche plus sur le côté télévision que
cinéma également avec boca tan un
personnage très important dans l'univers
qui fait son retour dans mandaloriennes
et qui va amener une intrigue très
importante pour jean jouines et bien
cette dernière a également
potentiellement une série prévue autour
de son histoire avant celle d'amanda
lauriane et on n'oublie pas évidemment
le film star wars prévu par kevin fait
guy le grand patron de marvel
un film qui évidemment aura des codes du
mc eu si disney fait appel à fait guy
c'est qu'il connaît ses capacités sur la
célèbre saga où tout est relié mais ce
qui m'intrigue personnellement du coup
est la fameuse trilogie de ryan johnson
le réalisateur de star wars 8
évidemment le point d'origine de star
wars reste les films et notamment les
trilogies
cependant l'histoire des skywalker est
terminée et donc nous sommes censés nous
diriger vers de l'inédit néanmoins des
oeuvres sorte avant cette trilogie et
surtout qui dit trilogie dit grosse
intrigue principale qui aura des suites
des spin off et c'est beaucoup spéculent
sur la possibilité d'une trilogie sur
l'ancienne république
mais au vu du rôle de mandat lauriane
qui est en train de lancer de nouvelles
intrigues et fait vivre à la fois des
nouveaux et revivre d'anciens éléments
on peut largement supposer que cette
nouvelle trilogie puisse avoir un
rapport de près ou de loin avec soin la
période où se passe le mandat lauriane
ou directement son scénario
en fait nous sommes enfin entre
guillemets sur de la nouveauté dans la
saga star wars mais un univers
s'agrémente au fil du temps et avec des
oeuvres qui garde un rapport
comme dans marvel ou par exemple la saga
amène un nouveau héros mais dont les
éléments de l'intrigué le lit
directement la trame principale comme
des objets la période où le héros
directement je vois mal en fait disney
sortir une trilogie qui n'aurait rien à
voir avec ce qui est déjà produit en ce
moment dans l'univers de star wars c'est
le meilleur moyen de perdre tout le
monde
après peut-être que je me trompe la
trilogie n'est pas prévu pour tout de
suite donc l'épopée du mandat lauriane
sera possiblement terminé d'ici là mais
il restera des traces de cette épopée à
coup sûr
est ce que vous voyez l'idée
dans tous les cas vous voyez cette vidéo
comme un retour pour moi dans la saga
je ne peux pas mentir que j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal avec star wars 9 et sam
a beaucoup freiné pour parler de la saga
mais aujourd'hui je suis totalement
relancé booster je m'intéresse à toutes
les ficelles de la saga et les trucs qui
manquaient comme rebelle par exemple
n'hésitez d'ailleurs pas à me dire ce
que vous aimeriez que l'on traite
ensemble sur star wars sur la chaîne je
lis tous vos commentaires toute façon
bref merci à tous ceux qu'il ait dont la
vidéo l'estran petit commentaire
s'abonneront je vous invite très
fortement à voir ma grosse vidéo
mon gros projet sur final fantasy 7
remake
bref c'était argot rock et que le
lionheart soit avec vous
[Musique]